many fandoms were devastated when Annie
woring died in January 2023 the actor
was widely known for her roles in shows
like 24 and Timeless as well as
supporting roles in Castle The Vampire
Diaries and the rookie woring also
notably performed motion capture and
voice acting for the iconic 2013 video
game The Last of Us as Tess woring also
appears as part of the main cast in
Marvel's runaways woring portrayed
Leslie Dean a religious leader and
mother to Virginia gardeners car Ala
Dean more recently in 2022 woring also
appeared in Star Trek pakad as the Bor
Queen sadly this wound up being wen's
final TV role the actor was diagnosed
with cancer in 2020 but kept her
realness a secret leading up to her
death in 2023 her condition had even
prevented her from making a guest
appearance in HBO's TV adaptation of The
Last of Us alongside other actors from
the games